mind your decisions presh tallwalker
here
in mathland birthdays are very important
by law a company has to give all of its
employees a holiday whenever any of its
employees has a birthday
also a company cannot discriminate based
on a person's birthday
the employees really enjoy the birthday
holidays because they work all other
days of a 365 day year
a company that hires too many employees
is doomed to have too many holidays but
a company that hires too few employees
will be understaffed
so a company hires you to do the math
how many workers should the company hire
so that it has the highest expected
person days worked per year
this problem is adapted from frederick
masteller's 50 challenging problems in
probability with solutions
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
suppose a company has n employees
an employee has a 1 over 365 chance to
be born each day
that means there's a 364 over 365 chance
that each day is not a person's birthday
the probability that a given day has no
birthdays will be the product of this
for each of the n employees this is
because each employee's birthday is
assumed to be an independent event
we'll group these terms together and we
get 364 over 365 to the power of n
now we need to take the expected
workdays which will be this sum over all
of the 365 days in the year we
substitute in the formula and then we
sum from 1 to 365 to get 365 multiplied
by 364 over 365 all to the power of n
now recall that the company has n
employees so the expected person work
days will be n multiplied by this
this is what we want to maximize
now we can use a clever little trick
since the natural log is a monotonically
increasing function we can equivalently
maximize the natural logarithm of this
function
so we maximize the logarithm
now we use the properties of logarithms
the product will turn into a sum
and then we take this exponent n and
bring it down
we can now take the first derivative to
find extrema
the first derivative is equal to 1 over
n plus the natural log of 364 over 365.
we can solve for where this is equal to
0 and we'll get n star is equal to
negative 1 over the natural log of 364
over 365.
notice the first derivative is greater
than 0 for values less than this and
it's less than 0 for values greater than
this thus we have a maximum
we now consider what value this is and
we get 364.5
approximately
we're considering whole numbers of
workers so we're going to test the cases
of n is equal to 364 and n is equal to
365.
we'll go back to the original form of
the function that we wanted to maximize
we'll then substitute in n is equal to
364 and n is equal to 365.
at first i thought these values were
different but thanks to some help at
math stack exchange they showed me why
these two are equal to each other
to see why let's convert the first
formula into the second
we'll multiply it by 365 over 365 which
is equal to one
now let's switch this 364 and 365.
we can then group these fractions
together and raise the exponent and lo
and behold we have two equal formulas
so the answer is either case is true n
is equal to 364 or n is equal to 365 and
that's the answer to the puzzle and it
works out to be approximately 48
943.5 person days
but there's one more fun aspect to this
puzzle we'll rewrite this formula as the
following
this will be equal to the expected work
days with holidays
now if there were no holidays at all 365
employees would work 365 days so that's
365 squared
if we take the ratio of these two
we'll cancel out these factors and we
end up with 1 minus 1 over 3 and 65 this
quantity raised to the power of 365.
interestingly this is approximately
equal to 1 over e
and the constant e comes out of nowhere
in mathlan even strange laws about
probability holidays lead to magical
surprises
thanks for being the best subscribers on
youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
you